-Wow.
That's what I'm talking about.
Hey. Are you --
-I uploaded it already.
-You did?
-I have the app.
-You have the --
You uploaded everything?
Oh, my gosh,
look at how good you look.
Come on.
Are you kidding me?
You are unbelievable.
Welcome back to the show
as always.
-These are cool.
-They're pretty fun, right?
-Yeah.
-Martha Stewart,
we have things to talk about.
-Yes, we do.
-Did you say hi to Bradley?
-I did.
I took a picture with him.
-You did?
-Yeah. And he looks --
-Lucky him.
-I watched the movie.
-Yeah.
Well, you knew
Leonard Bernstein.
-I knew the real Lenny.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-How did you know Lenny?
--Well, he lived in Fairfield
on the weekends,
and he also lived
right here in New York.
And I visited his apartment,
and we used to go
on Sunday afternoons for tea.
-What?!
-Yeah.
And his kids lived in Westport.
-And what was he like?
-Oh, the maestro.
-Yeah, he really is.
-Yeah.
-He's fantastic.
-He might have been
a little handsomer than...
-Than Bradley Cooper.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's what people say
about me all the time.
Oh, my God.
Just on the street they go,
"Hey, Bradley."
I go, "No, it's me, Jimmy."
-He was intense
like the Lenny in the movie.
Oh, boy, was --
Bradley is so amazing.
-I don't know how he does
all this stuff.
But you must
go to so many parties.
I mean, I know you throw
dinner parties, but you must --
I mean, attend a lot of parties.
-I go to a lot of
dinner parties,
and I go -- but I do have
a lot of dinner parties, too.
I have a table that seats
18 in my dining room,
and so I like
to fill it because --
And I live in a place --
you know,
I live in Bedford and Bedford
is like Beverly Hills.
I mean, there's so many movie
stars hanging out there now.
They're all moving to Bedford
for some reason.
-It's a happening place.
-Yeah. Happening.
And they're fun. They're fun.
I had Michael Kelly over
and I was a little scared of him
because he's played
pretty evil guys, you know?
-Oh, yeah.
But no. How was he?
-He was nice.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He was okay.
-Yeah.
You know, I've talked to people
that have had dinner
at your house
and they, they go --
I go, "How was it?"
And they go, "She's really fun."
-Oh, they did say that?
-Yeah.
-Like who?
-And I go, "What do you mean?
Of course she's really fun."
-I try to be fun.
-You are fun.
But maybe people go in thinking
that you're going to yell
at them or something.
-No. Why?
I don't yell at people.
-Have you ever yelled
at anyone at a dinner party?
-At my guests? No!
-"Hey, elbows off the table!"
-No, except
for the fire department
that came during one
very important dinner party
and some alarm went off
in my house someplace,
and the fire department
comes in with all the tools,
you know, the axes
and the hoses and everything.
And they tell everybody
to get out.
And it was like 20 degrees
below zero outside.
-And you're like, "Excuse me,
this is Snoop Dogg.
He's allowed to do this."
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, oh, Snoop Dogg,
talk about Snoop Dogg.
He came to dinner.
And, you know,
he said, "I'll be there --
About three guys, three guys.
We're just getting off the plane
and we have to go to New York.
But he'll stop by."
So I said, "Come for lunch."
And he came and seven bodyguards
and they're called
Teeny and Tiny
and they're all about
seven feet tall.
And they ate everything.
They ate everything
and left nothing
for the rest of the guests.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. He constantly
has the munchies.
-I had to make peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches
for my friends, you know.
Oh, my God, it was so --
-But you have
such a good relationship,
you and --
-Oh, he's great. Snoop is just
like my little brother.
-Yeah.
-I had three brothers,
but he was like the third --
he was like the fourth brother.
-Yeah.
Can we talk
about your shopping thing
that you got set up
on Amazon right now?
-Oh, yes. Please.
-This is what I want
to talk about.
Now, if you go on -- this
is "The World of Martha,"
"The World of Martha."
So you go on
"The World of Martha"
and you can choose
from anything.
And I've told you this, you've
been on the show so many times.
-Housewares,
kitchenwares, gadgets,
you know, all the good stuff
that you need for your home.
That's what it's all about.
-And you brought me a gift.
-Oh, I did. Look.
-Look at this.
It all comes all wrapped up.
You buy this
in "The World of Martha."
And I'm going to open it up.
[ Laughter ]
-So excited. Right?
What did you put in there?
Uh-oh.
-I can't wait, I can't wait,
I can't -- I'm so excited!
-Oh, a pot.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you just ruined
my Christmas present.
Oh, it has a cover, too.
-It has a cover. Yeah. Ow.
[ Laughter ]
-He ruined
my Christmas present.
Oh, my gosh.
-Thank you so much.
This is -- Thank you.
You know --
-You need one of these.
That is a very important pan
to have in your kitchen.
-When you get pot
from Snoop Dogg...
you get a different...
[ Laughter ]
You get pot from Martha Stewart,
you actually get an actual pot.
[ Laughter ]
Ba-dum-unh.
-But look how nice it is.
It's pretty.
-It actually is good quality.
It's gorgeous.
I do love the copper.
That's my move right there.
It looks very stylish.
Martha, thank you for this,
I appreciate it.
Was this for me?
-Yeah. Definitely. Yeah.
You can have anything you want.
You gave me these Meta glasses.
-Yeah.
Do you know you press the
button when you're having fun?
-Yeah, I know. I pushed --
I turned it on.
I don't know if they're charged
because it's not
really recording anything.
Oh, yeah. Look.
Oh, it changes color.
-Yeah. That's...
-Ooh!
-See what I'm saying.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, I see it. Hi. Yeah.
Look at that.
Yeah. Looking good.
-Oh, I can't wait.
-Get this, get this right here.
-Oh, yes.
-Get the Chardonnay.
Get the Martha Chard.
-Martha Chard.
Not Chardonnay. Chard.
-The Chard.
Tell me about this.
-Well, I've always wanted
to have a wine,
and I just thought, you know,
Martha Chard is so cool.
-Yeah.
-And I really worked on the --
I really worked on the wine.
I didn't just put
my picture on there.
-No, I know you.
-I really did.
And, you know, I picked
the grapes and I blended them
and put them --
-You didn't pick the grapes.
-I did so.
-You picked the grapes?
-Yeah.
Some of them.
Not all of them.
There's a lot of grapes.
-For the first couple bottles.
Yeah, it's a lot of grapes.
-But we got the blend right.
It's a delicious,
delicious Chardonnay.
Not too oaky, you know,
not too, you know,
it's really well-blended.
-You know your stuff.
And I know it's won
all these awards too.
-But you can use this
at Christmastime, you know,
because it's cold outside.
Make something mold with it.
You know, just warm it up.
-You brought
something for us here.
-I did, I did.
-Ooh. This is a mulled wine.
Now, what goes into this?
-So just a little bit
of fresh ginger,
a little orange peel,
a star anise.
-Star anise. I love this.
-Yes.
-Look at this.
-And a clover too.
This is fantastic.
-Warm your heart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mmm! Fantastic!
Yes, I'm having a good time.
Come on. Martha Stewart!
Check out "The World of Martha"
on Amazon.
Rufus and Martha Wainwright
perform for us after the break.
Stick around,
ladies and gentlemen.